voici la motivation des coureurs des
années 70 une certaine de drogue
[Musique]
voici leur motivation aujourd'hui
rien n'a changé à part peut-être
l'équipement car à son arrivée en france
l'atout de ce nouveau sport c'était son
faible coût c'est le sport le moins cher
une paire de tennis un short ou un
survêtement et surtout une envie de se
défouler de courir de se faire plaisir
dans l'effort et le plus souvent dans
les rues au milieu des voitures
un sport pas cher accessible à tous mais
rapidement les équipementiers flairent
le bon filon et certains stylistes était
visionnaire les stylistes de mode se
sont emparés du phénomène jogging comme
d'ailleurs de l'engouement actuel pour
le sport en général et ils ont réalisé
des vêtements qui ne sont plus réservées
aux seules activités sportives mais que
certains portent même à la vie je pense
que dans quelques années on verra
couramment des gens habillés en
survêtement pour travailler on est c'est
très confortable bon pressentiment
car le jogging est adoptée dans la vie
de tous les jours tout en continuant de
séduire les sportifs pas insensible à la
mode c'est à qui aura le plus beau
jogging au coton polyamide 250 francs
les équipementiers profite de ce filon
et innovent bilan dans les années 2000
on est bien loin de la course à pied bon
marché la priorité c'est donc
l'esthétique et les gadgets on ne court
plus sans capteur cardiaque sans
accéléromètre qui mesurent la vitesse et
la distance parcourue et bien sûr sans
musique
le nombre de coureurs ne cesse
d'augmenter passant de 6 millions en
2000 à 8 millions en 2010 et 12 millions
en 2018
presque tous deviennent accros aux
gadgets aux nouveaux survêtements et
aussi bien sûr au basket dernier cri à
200 euros
100 euros c'est vrai que ça paraît
beaucoup mais il ya une inflation
voronine qui fait que toutes les marques
bas sa ligne augmente et le prix sorte
de gage de qualité c'est comme dans
comment contenant le luxe voilà là la
running est enfin de devenir un objet de
luxe
il ya un loin du jogging en polyamide
bon marché
[Musique]